[Música]
los humanos conocen el sorprendente
pinchazo de una aguja el agudo dolor al
golpearse un dedo del pie Y el punzante
dolor de muelas podemos identificar
tipos de dolor y tener múltiples formas
de tratarlos Pero qué pasa con otras
especies Cómo experimentan el dolor los
animales que nos rodean
es importante que lo sepamos tenemos
animales como mascotas enriquecen
nuestro entorno criamos muchas especies
para nuestro alimento y experimentamos
con ellos para promover la ciencia y la
salud humana los animales son
importantes para nosotros por lo que es
muy importante que evitemos causarles
dolor innecesario en el caso de los
mamíferos a menudo es obvio cuando lo
cedimos
pero hay cosas que no son tan obvias
como si los analgésicos que funcionan en
nosotros también los ayudan Cuanto más
diferente sea un animal de nosotros
entender sus experiencias es más difícil
cómo se daría cuenta si un camarón una
serpiente o un caracol sienten dolor en
los vertebrados incluidos los humanos el
dolor puede ser separado en dos procesos
diferentes en primer lugar los nervios y
la piel sienten algo dañino y comunican
esa información a la médula espinal allí
las neuronas motoras activan movimientos
que nos hacen rápidamente huir de La
amenaza esto es el reconocimiento físico
del daño llamado nocicepción y lo
experimentan casi todos los animales
sin esta habilidad los animales serían
incapaces de huir del daño y su
supervivencia estaría amenazada
la segunda parte es el reconocimiento
consciente del daño en los humanos Esto
ocurre cuando las neuronas sensitivas en
la piel hacen una segunda Ronda de
conexiones desde la médula espinal al
cerebro allí millones de neuronas en
múltiples regiones crean las sensaciones
de dolor para nosotros es una compleja
experiencia asociada con emociones como
miedo pánico y estrés que podemos
comunicar a otros pero es difícil saber
cómo los animales experimentan esta
parte del proceso Porque muchos de ellos
no demuestran lo que sienten
sin embargo tenemos pistas al observar
Cómo se comportan los animales
los animales salvajes y heridos son
conocidos por cuidar sus heridas hacen
sonidos para mostrar su dolor y se
vuelven solitarios los científicos han
descubierto que los animales como pollos
o ratas se autoadministran fármacos para
reducir el dolor cuando están heridos
los animales también huyen de
situaciones donde han sido heridos antes
lo que sugiere conciencia de las
amenazas
esta investigación nos asegura que los
vertebrados reconocen el dolor con lo
que es ilegal en muchos países herir
innecesariamente a estos animales
Pero qué sucede con otros tipos de
animales como los invertebrados estos
animales no están legalmente protegidos
en parte porque su comportamiento es
difícil de comprender podemos hacer
buenas conjeturas sobre algunos como las
ostras los gusanos y las medusas Estos
son ejemplos de animales sin cerebro o
con uno muy simple
una ostra retrocederá si se le chorrea
jugo de limón debido a la nocicepción
pero al tener un sistema nervioso simple
Es improbable que experimente la parte
consciente del dolor otros animales
invertebrados son más complicados como
el pulpo que tiene un cerebro
sofisticado e incluso es uno de los
animales invertebrados más inteligentes
aún así en muchos países la gente sigue
la práctica de comer vivo al pulpo
incluso hervimos vivos a langostas
camarones y cangrejos a pesar de que no
sabemos cómo les afecta esto nos plantea
un problema ético porque les podemos
estar causando un sufrimiento
innecesario la experimentación
científica aunque controversial nos da
algunas pistas pruebas en cangrejos
Ermitaños muestran que dejan su
caparazón si reciben electricidad Pero
se quedan si es un buen caparazón y los
pulpos que pueden enrollar un brazo
herido para protegerlo arriesgan usarlo
para cazar a sus presas esto sugiere que
estos animales hacen juicios de valor de
la entrada sensorial en vez de solo
reaccionar reflexivamente al daño se
sabe que los cangrejos se frotan el
punto de sus cuerpos donde han recibido
un choque eléctrico incluso las babosas
de mar se encogen cuando saben que están
cerca de recibir un estímulo nocivo eso
significa que tienen cierta memoria de
las sensaciones físicas aún tenemos
mucho que aprender sobre el dolor animal
a medida que nuestro conocimiento crece
algún día podremos vivir en un mundo
donde no causemos dolor innecesario
ya que estamos en el tema de lo que
sucede en el mundo animal Alguna vez se
ha preguntado Por qué los gatos actúan
tan extrañamente o cómo los perros ven
usando la nariz obtenga respuestas a
estas preguntas importantes haciendo
clic en uno de estos videos